Looking a little rough around the edges, so let's judge other people's appearances
Hi my name is Grace Helbig! If you did not know, now you know, your life is different now! The VMA's happened over the weekend.
Let's review some of the red Carpet fashions or whatever. I mean was like a hologram carpet
I don't know. What do they do kids these days. I hate myself your opposite
I would likely miss people that you wanted me to talk about so I'm sorry I can't please all of you
Subscribe Kesha
You look like a cake topper
That has some chucks in your tits what this is cool. You like Glenda the goodwitch that also knows karate
Look like Chuck Norris is Fairy Godmother
You know Haley Baldwin wow like you walk through the most beautiful spider web
Or like all of the blood in your veins, just froze looks like a unicorn came off, okay?
Very cute Palestine feel Steve your Stern's dance to monsterpiece beer
I love sting you look adorable. This was very
my
Super-sweet grecian 16 like an elementary school art class made a bunch of fans and tape them into a dress for you cute
Thank you, Minaj. Oh, just a badass girl bow wow bring pink pepto-bismol 8x10 Cooter's gotta be
In pain you who needs spanx when your outfit is. Thanks. The shoes look like hot couture power rangers
You look like more like a sex blow-up
Doll that definitely probably just like talks about you behind your back when you leave the room yeah pink
What bank did you just come from I think it's awesome. I love when women wear more
Masculine attire, they're like a very fashionable version of the Monopoly man
You can't remove wall street, and you just got done doing blow off with some girl's vagina. You checked your pocket watching right?
Oh my God the vmas are starting
Scammer what yeah Billy Bobby brown you're just growing up before our eyes
That's creepy to say you look adorable and uncomfortable like they let you out of boot camp for the day
And you didn't have a dress to wear to the ball. So you just took the shower curtain and
Did what you could cute mel B. Well I'll be damned that you're Bi looks amazing
Wow
You will never own me is what the dress says that
Seems like a direct message to someone she's not signing into anyone's Dm. She's just messaging
Directly Jim Harmony. I heard they threw shade at Camila
This is the most disconnected that they've looked to me on a red carpet is this a sign that they might
I
Don't know conspiracy theories. Sorry you all look absolutely beautiful you all look like you're not in the same group
But that's okay Obama is holding a birdcage because duh I like this sexy red thing
I can't tell if it's a dress or if it's a jumpsuit or if it's how it's on your body, but
beautiful and the birdcage nothing says I don't need attention like carrying a birdcage down the
Olivia munn, I love this dress. I want to own it
That's all you look great. Lord. O lord so much and some might say this is an awkward stance
But I think this is just lowered being Lord
She killed a snuffleupagus, and then dip died an ace bandage who called it a dress and I'm all for it. Hey perry
this is
Geometrically confusing but your tits look great is as cool like a picasso painting on your body space Sharon stone cute
Noah cyrus or any 16 to 20 year old youtuber girl. I think this is fun
it's like you got your boyfriend's sweatshirt and your dominatrix mom's boots and you've stolen dad's glasses and your
Grandma's Choker and You made it work cute, Vanessa Hudgens
This is cool. I think that netting makes me feel a little claustrophobic
You look like you got little mama's birdcage at the bottom half of your body
Cute. This is Amber Rose which thank god to the internet knows because I would never have known. You look beautiful with brown hair.
You look like a pageant queen you look like a wax figure also. Are you okay? Blink if you need help, okay?
Cute Shawn Mendes looking like Shawn Mendes. America's sweetheart and does your shirt have S's and M's on it?
Someone is upping their branding game. Thank you
Paris Jackson gods and goddesses on this netting thing, but it's over like a
painter way
Bra and underwear set. Very Coachella meets fruit of the loom cute. GG gorgeous
You just you, do it every time
How do you do it every time? This looks very
Like what you wear under your wedding dress on your wedding night that you're like here we go
Carry me across the threshold and let's seal this deal. Cute.
This is machine gun Kelly
This is what machine gun Kelly looked  like this whole time?
Why didn't you guys tell me this?
He's the baby
He's very attractive, baby
I'm moving on. Jay versace. Oh my God
This kid is so funny, and he looks like a cartoon character, and I love it
And he's having a great time, and I love it. You look like a box of Crayola Crayons Puked all over Mr.. Rogers and
I'm here for it. Demi lovato. Whoa. This is like a sex genie cool
I like these glitter Harem pants with this
Lace thing well looks like you got a bunch of Henna all over the top half here
We come and it feels great, then give me those
Harem pants you put your pants so many times during the show and no one would have any idea cute Andrea russett it
You look like a princess
Oh my God doors look so badass unlike Rocker punk chic that I sound so old right now
This is so soft and demure and pretty look at you
I'm so proud of you. This is like hygiene goals ass okay
I know I probably missed a ton of people that you want me to comment on so for that again
I am sorry
But let me know what you thought of the looks at the vmas this year leave a comment down below
Click subscribe because I make videos Monday Wednesday and Friday
Sometimes I don't and sometimes I do it differently said don't know why I keep saying that and other than that. I don't know
Heidi Klum is there a girl is back?
I was missing her and a lot of events lately, and I'm really glad she made this one and damn
Boi-Oi-oi-oi-oing her hair looks so healthy